Tennyson I get the sense that you have a
pretty amazing intuition thank you for
the emails we've had back and forth and
just just me today I just hit that sense
yeah how do you use this intuition to
interact in your career I mean can you
give us examples we're going with your
gut or having a hunch about something
either protected you from something or
in turn created something amazing mmhmm
yeah sure okay well um I think I think
by and large that's it's true all the
way along there were quite a few people
telling me the starline record wasn't
going to work creatively um because web
shows are supposed to be three minutes
long and because dramatic web shows
never really work to begin with and
there again you know I just went with
the basic principles of drama my
objective was just to give every actor a
strong clear objective to take from the
beginning of everything that they were
into the end of every scene that they
were in and to trust that that would and
then to make sure that all those actions
light up to bigger actions that they
were trying to accomplish from the
beginning of the series to the end of
the series which is what the arc is
about and that there were enough people
trying to stop them that it seemed
likely that they would fail especially
given whatever tools they had you know
and what you end up with in that story
was probably the two people you would
least want in charge of first contact
with an extraterrestrial intelligence
being at the epicenter of the most
important event in human history and
documenting it for the world and their
challenge was to get information from
Dean who was this possibly at the
beginning of the series possessed person
or something had happened to him where
he was getting information from a place
that he should not be able to get it
from was but at the same time he
couldn't express it so they were trying
to figure out how to get information I
mean how to draw blood from a stone was
their objective and they kid they
couldn't even get him out of the closet
the first episode was just about them
trying to get him out and have him show
you the thing that led them to believe
that something crazy what's happening to
begin with and by and by they start to
piece together enough tools to be
dangerous and to start pulling some
information out of the situation and it
just makes everything worse
when they do because all of a sudden
they've opened themselves up to this
whole world they're not ready for and um
and people do enjoy it you know it's
it's a cheap series we spent 3 grand
less than three grand I think on it
maybe maybe a couple hundred bucks more
it's on IMDb you can look it up I forget
but the point is you know people people
really have enjoyed on that basis and
it's just about trusting the
fundamentals but yeah they were playing
people who are like that's not a web
series I'm like sure it is trust me so
you went with your gut it worked for you
oh it was great it's a great show I'm
still proud of it you know I think it's
a lot of fun to watch i watch it today
it holds up for me I'm not embarrassed
by it which is I think every filmmaker
can agree the most important like wow
okay you know a year later and I don't
cringe
you